Donald J Trump real-estate tycoon
billionaire reality TV star obviously a
voice for the working American right a
man who says whatever he wants however
he wants to say it no matter how untrue
no matter how tasteless definitely the
person we want negotiating on our behalf
with the rest of the world a candidate
with few details as to how he will solve
the country's problems or follow through
with his promises but that's alright
he'll hire the best people he'll get
things done and he'll make America great
again because we don't win anymore and
Donald Trump will make America win again
it's surely been a strange and
interesting journey following the rise
of Trump but Trump is dug himself quite
a deep hole with some of his latest
remarks which might even be more
outrageous than usual and the degree to
which he's been trailing Hillary Clinton
at this stage in the game is beginning
to suggest that something quite
remarkable would need to happen for him
to recover in the race before November
let's take an in-depth look into the
2016 Republican Party candidate being a
good business person has never proven to
have any correlation with having
knowledge about economics or having
competence as a leader in government but
Donald Trump suppose at expertise in
business has been his only claim to a
credential in this race for president
Trump said in an interview with Rolling
Stone magazine I'm running for office in
a country that's essentially bankrupt
and it needs a successful businessman
Donald Trump started his career in real
estate with extraordinary training
wheels when Trump graduated from college
his father a real estate mogul in New
York City one of the richest people in
America as Trump puts it it has not been
easy for me my father gave me a small
loan of a million dollars of course what
Trump often doesn't mention is that in
addition to that one million dollars
that his father gave him he inherited
around 40 million dollars he was handed
his father's real estate empire and he
directly benefited from his father's
connections and excellent credit as I
and many others have pointed out in the
past if Trump had taken that
approximately 40 million dollars that he
received from his father decades ago and
instead of pursuing any business
ventures
so ever had instead put them into
everyday run-of-the-mill index funds and
left the money untouched Trump would be
much richer than he is today
he hasn't provided any proof to the
American people as to how much he's
worth Forbes estimates 4.1 billion
dollars Bloomberg News estimates 2.9
billion dollars but if he had instead
just invested the money he got from his
father he could have accumulated 13
billion dollars you would have to be
particularly incompetent to be
unsuccessful in real estate in New York
City when given such a head start and
the financial foundation that Donald
Trump had and plenty of American
billionaires have had far more success
starting with much less Trump's
accomplishments in real estate have been
average at best and a large amount of
the success he has had especially during
the latter part of his career has come
from licensing out the Trump brand to
projects instead of financing building
and owning projects himself Trump allows
other companies to put the Trump name on
their property and sits back and
collects the profits but while working
on projects that he did own he's
declared bankruptcy four times and has
failed to pay hundreds and hundreds of
different companies that he's done
business with and outside of real estate
Trump has had a long list of miserable
failures in other industries and Trump
is proven time and again that his time
in the business world has given him very
little economic insight in 1991 Trump
said publicly that Japan's economy was
quote totally brilliant right as the
Japanese economy began going into a now
infamous ten-year recession in 1999
Trump said the u.s. was about to
experience quote an economic crash like
we've never seen before
worse than the one in 1929 this was
right before a large boost to the
American economy and in 2006 shortly
before the great recession caused by the
burst of the housing bubble Donald Trump
created his company Trump mortgage
saying quote I think it's a great time
to start a mortgage company the real
estate market is going to be very strong
for a long time to come the next year
Trump's mortgage company folded in the
u.s. saw the beginning of the worst at
Namah collapse since the Great
Depression the art of the deal the book
that Donald Trump is always touting and
telling people to read telling
government leaders to read because it's
such a great guide to business and
negotiation turns out Trump didn't even
write it it was written by author Tony
Schwartz Trump may not have any
experience in government leadership and
he may not be the self-made man and
business genius that he often gets
credit for but what really matters is
whether Donald Trump is looking out for
the little guy
does he have moral fiber as a human
being The Smoking Gun an organization
that publishes and analyzes legal
documents reviewed IRS documents filed
by Trump over the last 25 years and
concluded that Trump is probably the
least charitable billionaire in the
entire United States although he
characterizes himself as a proud New
Yorker Donald Trump gave one small
donation to September 11 relief $1,000
to a Scientologists charity and by the
way he received a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in federal 9/11 relief
money that was supposed to go to small
businesses that were affected by the
attacks some of the largest donations
that Donald Trump has ever made have
been donations to his own children
schools donations the Jenny McCarthy's
anti vaccination organization donations
that earned him conservation related
land development tax breaks and a
donation of land to the state of New
York for the creation of Donald J Trump
State Park when Trump donated the
property it happened to have been
contaminated with asbestos records show
that Donald Trump has given absolutely
nothing to the Trump foundation since
2008 a charitable organization that his
own company set up and over a 19 year
period the wrestling company World
Wrestling Entertainment of all people
had given more money to Trump's own
foundation than Trump himself had given
this year the IRS and the Federal
Election Commission accused Trump of
violating federal election laws by
exploiting his charities at his
political rallies and using charitable
donations for political gain this was
after Trump
had already been deceptively funneling
veterans donations into his own
foundation for months
Trump is had a number of incidents
involving charities in the past that are
thought to probably constitute fraud
under federal law for example while
promoting is for-profit company called
Trump University Trump claimed that at
least some proceeds would go to charity
none ever did
speaking of Trump University it is
currently the subject of two federal
lawsuits in one state lawsuit accusing
the company of a number of illegal
activities including false claims and
racketeering getting more than five
thousand people to pay up to thirty five
thousand dollars each to the alleged
scam suspiciously attorneys general in
two separate states that have been
investigating Trump University decided
to drop the probes right before
receiving large donations from Trump to
their respective elections in one of the
trials that did come to fruition Trump
called the federal judge Spanish and
said that the proceedings were unfair
because the judge was of Mexican descent
this brings us to trump's personality in
terms of impulse control none of us have
ever seen
probably american history has never seen
a major presidential candidate that
carries himself like donald trump who
will say anything despite any lack of
rationality decorum or thought
whatsoever trump has actually tried to
spin this as a positive arguing he's not
going to shy away from telling quote the
truth because of political correctness
at this point Trump has said and done
dozens upon dozens of things that would
immediately disqualify any other
candidate in the eyes of voters imagine
a headline where Hillary Clinton has
said that she doesn't like John McCain
because he was captured and was a
prisoner of war
so I'd never liked them as much after
that because I don't like religious
but yours he's a war hero because he was
captured I like people that weren't
captured okay I hate to tell you or
imagine if you heard that Ted Cruz had
mocked a disabled person I don't know
what I said
I don't remember he's gonna like I don't
remember either Oh baby that's what I
said or if you saw Jeb Bush on TV
calling Mexicans rapists they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists it is unimaginable these
candidates poll numbers would have
tanked instantly and never recovered
this all speaks to Trump being unfit for
the presidency but above all else we
should be judging Donald Trump is a
candidate based on his policy positions
and his values about governing these
values are of course difficult to nail
down and take seriously since Trump has
flip-flopped on a wide variety of issues
supported and donated to Democrats and
taken multiple or every possible
position on many issues many of his
positions during the 2016 campaign have
been the polar opposites of what he's
espoused in the past are you for
invading Iraq yeah I guess so
obviously the war in Iraq was a big fat
mistake all right
Gaddafi in Libya is killing thousands of
people and we're sitting around we're
soldiers all over the Middle East and
we're not bringing them in now we should
go in we should stop this guy which
would be very easy and very quick he
said I was in favor of Libya I was I
never discussed that subject I was in
favor of Libya we would be so much
better off if Qaddafi were in charge
right now in 2000 his book the America
we deserve he advocated an assault
weapon ban and a longer waiting period
for gun purchases now Trump's latest gun
plan calls for a national right to
concealed carry now he has vowed to undo
President Obama's modest gun executive
orders he also wants to get rid of all
the gun-free zones at schools
everybody's gonna be taking much better
than taking care of now the uninsured
person right is gonna be taking care
gonna be taking universal health care I
am going to take care of everybody and
everybody's got to be covered the
government's gonna pay for it but we're
gonna save so much money on the other
side Donald true or false you said the
government should pay for everyone
health care that's false you've never
said that I'm I'm very pro-choice but
you would not ban it no or ban
partial-birth Anil I would I would I am
I am pro-choice in every respect I hate
the concept of abortion should abortion
be punished it has to be some form of
punishment for the woman yeah but let's
take a look at what he says he believes
now and what he tells us he would do as
president Trump's economic advisors are
his biggest campaign donors like real
estate billionaire Steve Roth real
estate billionaire Thomas barrack and
oil executive billionaire Harold Hamm
Trump wants to do away with what little
financial reform we even have now to
curb Wall Street recklessness when asked
what he would do about Wall Street Trump
says quote I would say
it'll be close to dismantling dodd-frank
dodd-frank is a very negative force
which has developed a very bad name
Trump wants to cut taxes by 12 trillion
dollars the top 1% wealthiest people in
the US would see 37% of those tax cuts
and most people in America would see
basically no change to their taxes both
progressive and conservative analysts
have said that this plan is beyond
untenable a Washington Post study finds
that trumps tax cuts would add about 10
trillion dollars to the national debt
during his campaign Trump a switch back
and forth between either supporting no
increase to the federal minimum wage or
abolishing it altogether
he's now seeming to stick to a ten
dollar federal minimum wage but it's
hard to tell if he's even convinced
about what should happen so you go with
the states like the states have the
authority now to do that but there has
to be a federal gonna mum wage what
would you set the federal minimum wage
doesn't have to be well I I would leave
it and raise it somewhat we'll give me
Jimmy Channel uncle but 10 I would say
10 I would say 10 Barra Trump is
anti-science he doesn't believe that
climate change is man-made he said
multiple times that it is a hoax made up
by the Chinese he's talked about banning
all Muslims from the US as well as
tracking them in a database
he's backpedaled on these statements to
varying degrees and it's still a little
tough to tell where he currently stands
Trump wants to end restrictions on
assault weapons high-capacity magazines
and military-style weapons and allow
people to carry concealed weapons
everywhere including in schools Trump is
also back pedaled on what has been his
landmark promise during the election his
pledge to deport all 11 million
undocumented immigrants in one fell
swoop to the dismay of many of his
supporters he has shown everyone how
unsure he is about immigration policy
doing a complete 180 on things that he
guaranteed he would do and anyone with
any common sense knows that Mexico will
not pay for a wall along our entire
southern border despite the fact that
he's held by his supporters as a
champion of free speech and non
political correctness he wants to turn
the laws against journalists in
mind-boggling and seemingly
unconstitutional ways we're going to
open up the libel laws so when they
write falsely we can sue the media and
we can get the story corrected and get
damages right Bolivia he has had a
disdain for the press who have in
general gone easy on him he's whined
about newspapers and news channels he
doesn't like he's an extremely
thin-skinned
Pro censorship candidate Trump has said
disturbing things about nuclear war
including if we have nuclear weapons why
can't we use them as well as saying that
nuking Europe is not out of the question
a foreign policy expert on international
level went to advise Donald Trump and
three times he asked about the use of
nuclear weapons three times he asked at
one point if we have them why can't we
use them almost all of his policy
prescriptions have been vague and
unsubstantiated he rarely gives any type
of details as to how he's going to fix
anything or even fulfill his own
promises with Crump all you ever get is
hey you can trust me because I'm going
to hire the right people China will be
sorry the people we have in the White
House are stupid we need someone who can
make deals we need someone who can bring
back the American Dream and that's what
I'm going to do folks that I can tell
you but almost everything that Trump has
actually concretely suggested or
promised to do that's been specific or
tangible has been completely ludicrous
implausible impossible to finance or
just outright tyrannical it seems like
one of the best things that Trump
supporters are able to say about their
candidate is that this is all just an
act
all just theatrical off-the-cuff
hyperbole that's necessary to rally the
public and that soon we'll see the real
Trump a rational knowledgeable
collective leader worthy of being our
commander-in-chief but if that were true
and there was actually a policy expert
somewhere underneath it all a
level-headed in presidential leader with
thorough nuanced understandings of
anything relevant to the presidency
Middle East politics economics the legal
system social issues don't you think we
would have seen some indications by now
any signs whatsoever don't you think by
this point Trump would have given us at
least a few glimpses at a version of
himself that isn't just a total lay
person with a buffoonish demeanor the
success of Donald Trump in the 2016 race
says a lot of unfortunate things about
our country this candidate has no
experience the only thing that people
hold as his qualification is his
business expertise which is questionable
at best and isn't even a relevant
credential to begin with he proves
everyday that he has a temperament
totally unsuited to be president of the
United States the face of this country
he proves every day that he has no
policy knowledge nowhere near enough to
be the commander-in-chief of the most
powerful military in the world or the
leader of the biggest economy in the
world Donald Trump belongs nowhere near
the White House